[Música]
Bienvenidos a nuestro espacio diario
dedicado al desarrollo de la cop 27 que
recordemos tiene lugar en charmel Shake
Egipto ahí tenemos a dos enviadas
especiales Marina Colorado y María Clara
calle hoy nos informan que miles de
personas en el mundo están a un paso de
quedarse Sin comida una situación
agravada por la crisis climática hoy en
la cop27 la organización de la ONU para
la alimentación y la agricultura lanzó
junto con Egipto la iniciativa llamada
Fast que aspira a transformar la manera
en que se cultivan y se producen los
alimentos para garantizar la seguridad
alimentaria Pero cómo están relacionados
la agricultura y el cambio climático
para entenderlo vamos ahora con María
Clara calle como decíamos una de
nuestras enviadas especiales a
charmelshake María Clara Buendía qué más
ha pasado hoy ya sobre los temas del día
de la Cumbre climática
y cuando se discute la agricultura en la
cop 27 nosotros también nos dedicamos a
este tema estamos con Daniel mochamp el
director global de adaptación para la
organización de nature conservas y
Daniel un placer que esté aquí con
nosotros y los alimentos y el uso de
tierras ocupan o producen mejor el 25%
de los gases de efecto invernadero que
contaminan la tierra una de las posibles
soluciones es la agricultura
regenerativa explícanos por favor En qué
consiste Y si ha tenido cabida esta
discusión o no en la cop 27 la
agricultura regenerativa es darle un
enfoque de conservación a procesos de
producción de alimentos y ahí cuando
hablamos de agricultura regenerativa
hablamos a veces de plantar árboles
dentro de cultivos pero va mucho más
allá Es sobre el tema se trata sobre el
tema de
mejorar la y regenerar el suelo que haya
más lombrices que haya más Vida Natural
fertilizantes sintéticos para que
también haya más aves más biodiversidad
se trata de Pues de mejorar el ciclo del
agua facilitar el ciclo del agua
eliminar fertilizantes como decía con un
fin también de cultivar la resiliencia y
la adaptación al cambio climático la
agricultura regenerativa por lo tanto es
una parte bien importante y es una un
factor clave porque como bien dices toma
es gran vamos si lleva mucho lleva mucha
carga en cuanto a las emisiones globales
entonces hay que trabajar mucho el tema
regenerativo agrícola una de las cosas
más interesantes que han pasado ahora
aquí en la cop 27 ha sido recientemente
el anuncio de 14 de los grandes negocios
de agricultura que han decidido
acordar una mapa de ruta para llegar a
un calentamiento máximo de 1.5 y esto
significa en muchas en buena parte
eliminar frenar la deforestación porque
cuando hablamos de agricultura hablamos
definitivamente de bosques y usted
mencionó algo cultivar
experiencia y la adaptación Cómo se
vinculan estos dos temas precisamente
Cuando tenemos una crisis alimentaria en
lugares del mundo como el cuerno de
África como decía cuando hablamos de
agricultura Tenemos que hablar de
bosques cuando hablamos la agricultura
está muy muy muy afectada por el cambio
climático
variaciones en las temperaturas
variaciones en la cantidad de agua que
cae en la intensidad con que cae la
lluvia la sequías todo esto influye
muchísimo y afecta muchísimo la
productividad si una vamos a tener
buenas cosechas y vamos a perder
cosechas entonces adaptar la agricultura
y de maneras naturales como es la
agricultura regenerativa que no requiera
más insumos porque los insumos también
requieren entonces mayor nivel de
endeudamiento de los pequeños
agricultores por ejemplo Entonces
llegaron a maneras naturales de avanzar
pues es bien importante la vinculación
Entonces por último la frontera agrícola
la frontera agrícola está está
expandiéndose enormemente hacia el
bosque entre en los últimos 30 años en
América Latina perdimos en deforestación
el equivalente a todo el territorio del
Perú o a la mitad de la Argentina
y sobre todo por temas de agricultura
para generar más producción de alimentos
entonces trabajar el tema de la
deforestación y apoyar la reforestación
es fundamental para apoyarnos solo un
sistema agrícola más sustentable sino
también una adaptación y vamos a ir una
una desaceleramiento del calentamiento
global y por tanto Pues que la
adaptación sea una meta más lograble más
fácil o menos difícil quizás Así es
Ojalá sea menos difícil Daniel Gracias
por estar con nosotros y continúen
ustedes mientras nosotros Seguimos aquí
con el cubrimiento completo de la cop 27
a nuestras enviadas especiales Muchas
gracias por su reporte y a ustedes
Muchas gracias por su atención sigan con
nosotros
[Música]